Marvel Studios is reportedly going to
recast Iron Man Captain America and
Black Widow but pay attention to what
I'm about to say next because it is very
important that you know the difference
in what is being reported on right now
Robert Downey Jr Chris Evans and
Scarlett Johansson are reportedly still
coming back to the MCU as Iron Man as
Captain America and as Black Widow but
as variants of their old characters
meaning they are not going to to be the
exact same people from the 616 universe
so not the same Iron Man we know not the
same Captain America we know or black
widow they could be similar in every
single way but still just be from a
different Universe Kevin fagy has
already said they're not going to revive
these characters and we'll talk about
that in this video as well but here's
the difference in what I'm talking about
these three actors are going to return
to their original roles in Avengers
Secret Wars just as variants and then
after Avengers Secret Wars after these
legendary actors have returned to their
legendary characters making cameos in
the film Marvel Studios is reportedly
going to recast these characters in a
soft reboot for the new MCU post
Avengers Secret Wars and according to
this report it's going to be for a very
specific reason now right away go ahead
and let me know how you feel about that
some could consider this The Best of
Both Worlds we get Robert Downey Jr
returning as Iron Man Chris Evans as
Captain America and Scarlett Johansson
as Black Widow R turning temporarily for
cameos in one movie but then we get the
characters back permanently in the MCU
Post Secret Wars but they would be
played by different actors so the old
Legends returned but the characters
continue on in the MCU and let's be
honest we knew that Marvel Studios
wasn't going to Forever write off Iron
Man Captain America and Black Widow we
knew these characters were going to
return and be recast eventually and
according to this report if you hear
what Marvel Studios reported has planned
maybe you'll really like what's about to
happen with the mcu's soft reboot so
let's dive into it but of course if
you're new to the channel be sure to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on the latest MCU news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner picks one
item we pick one winner at the end of
every single month so lots of
opportunities to win so first things
first variety did an article on Robert
Downey Jr and in this article they have
a quote from Kevin feige talking about
the resurrection of specifically Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man from the 616
Universe our main MCU Universe the
sacred timeline whatever you want to
call it what we've been watching for
over a decade now and what he basically
confirms is that Robert Denny Jr's Iron
Man they're not just going to bring him
back to life and Marvel in the comics is
known to do this characters return all
the time as the same exact character now
of course sometimes they can return as
different characters but Kevin is
specific spefically talking about Robert
Downey Jr's 616 Iron Man and he says
this in this interview the paragraph in
the Vanity Fair article reads after 10
films dowy Iron Man made his exit in
2019s Avengers endgame still a high
water mark for the series Marvel has a
reputation for resurrecting characters
who seemingly meet their ends but fige
says that won't happen to Stark and I
quote we are going to keep that moment
and not touch that moment again we all
worked very hard for many years to get
to that and we would never want to
magically undo it in any way end quote
so the 616 Tony Stark who died in
Avengers endgame truly died they are not
resurrecting him they are not bringing
him back so all of the reports that
we've heard recently about Robert dowy
Jor returning as Iron Man clearly seemed
to be about him returning to play a
variant of himself which of course is
still going to be insanely cool in fact
I think it's the best scenario I think a
lot of people would agree with what
Kevin fi said in this article that we
shouldn't resurrect Iron Man we
shouldn't take away his death and his
sacrifice the same thing goes for Logan
when we found out that Wolverine was
going to be returning Hugh Jackman was
returning to play him the first
statement they kind of really made was
that they're not going to undo what
happened in Logan the same thing goes
for Professor X Patrick Stewart made it
very clear that he said goodbye to that
character in Logan and that was the
character's death however when he
returned in Multiverse of Madness to
play Professor X again that was a
different variant so they didn't undo
what he did the same thing goes with
Wolverine it's just going to be a
variant so it seems pretty clear that
when Robert Downey Jr Chris Evans and
Scarlett Johansson return they'll be
playing variants of their old characters
however I really hope Chris Evans also
plays the Human Torch again and the
original Fantastic 4 show up but now as
far as recasting these iconic characters
goes we have a report from The Insider
my time to shine hello that basically
tells us that secret wars during it and
after it will basically be a soft reboot
which we had already heard about and
they will use this to bring back Iron
Man Captain Captain America and Black
Widow with new actors somebody asked The
Insider on Twitter what's it looking
like in regards to Secret Wars soft
rebooting the MCU can we expect to see
new actors playing Tony Steve and
Natasha Post Secret Wars so we'll
finally be getting those characters in
the same universe as the X-Men Fantastic
4 Etc in which she replied yes to all of
it confirming three things the soft
reboot the confirmation of new actors
playing Iron Man Captain America and
Black Widow and the reason basically
being so they can interact with the
X-Men and the Fantastic 4 who we know
are going to play pretty prominent roles
in the MCU moving forward Post Secret
Wars so this is incredible news and
right now I know that the MCU has been
in sort of a funk for a lot of people
but I still have very very high hopes
for the remaining projects in the
Multiverse Saga and I actually think
it's going to end very very strong and I
think Deadpool 3 is really going to
start to show us the true potential of
the Multiverse Saga we got into it a
little bit with Multiverse of Madness
and Spider-Man no way home but Deadpool
is really going to take us there so I
think the end with the X-Men showing up
a lot of old original actors like
Electra Jennifer Gardner showing up
basically all the cameos that we've been
hearing about all of the actors
returning to play these old iconic roles
and the Multiverse truly starting to
collapse I truly believe Secret Wars is
going to be a huge movie and if Marvel
Studios can pick up the pace and hype
again with Deadpool 3 and their projects
after which I do believe they can do
then we could be looking at the
possibility of Avengers Secret Wars
being the biggest movie of all time just
like Avengers endgame was because on a
scale it's certainly bigger so I'm
really excited for that but if that
doesn't get you excited it sounds like
Post Secret Wars phase 7 or maybe since
it's a soft reboot they go back to phase
one 1.1 whatever they decide to do it
sounds like it's going to be pretty much
the universe that we have all wanted
from the very beginning a universe in
which not only do the Avengers exist and
the classic Avengers characters like
Iron Man Black Widow and Captain America
are there but the X-Men exist in this
universe they exist alongside of them
and interact with them as well as the
Fantastic for as well this is basically
an MCU with nothing off limits every
character can finally be used and
literally any interaction could happen
in the MCU moving forward in this soft
reboot so if that doesn't get you
excited about the future of Marvel I'm
not really sure what could but I also
want to say that I do like that it's
still a plan to do a soft reboot after
because that means everything that our
original Heroes have done really just
any hero up to this point in the MCU and
up to Secret Wars is not going to be
just erased out of existence like it
never happened but it'll still be there
I'm assuming we're probably going to end
up in another Universe after Secret Wars
not 616 anymore but a lot of people from
616 will end up in this new universe as
well which is how we could get a new
Iron Man Captain America Black Widow Etc
while still keeping the memories of what
all of the original Heroes have done I
think it's a brilliant idea but go ahead
and let me know your thoughts about all
of this in the comments down below do
you like this do you not like it do you
not want them to recast let us know
everything down below please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date on the MCU you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter as well
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof